oh
out of curiosity uh some of my um
life might be a bit vivid you're not uh
or
elusive or
um
on the other side which i would consider
evil spectrum
okay would you would you consider would
y'all would you be judgmental towards me
not at all
my uncle before we even get started
my uncle
pressed charges against me for indecency
with a minor
against his daughter
and i wound up getting it dropped to
assault
because he was uh manipulative and was
using which was uh
trying to get five thousand dollars for
my grandmother
and he used me
and as uh as a way to get to my
grandmother because i was living with my
grandmother
and he um
since he didn't get the five thousand
dollars he had me locked away in prison
for no reason
how old were you
huh how old were you and this happened
23 how old was she
oh how old was i oh oh no how was i i
was 16 and it didn't happen
how old was the girl
uh she was about seven or eight
well here let's just let's just start
from the beginning do you want me to
just use the assault part instead of the
other part no you can you can mention it
all
okay i'm not being judged or am i not at
all
i don't know i don't do that what uh
what is your name my name is ernest
ernesto where'd you grow up where you
from
i'm was born in texas i lived in
i lived there for about 30 years i lived
in mississippi for about three months
but i came from louisiana i lived in
louisiana for pretty close to six and a
half years
i moved from monroe louisiana
okay and tell me about your childhood
you had mom and dad
mom and well
i was actually adopted
i i'm actual i'm actually the son one of
the sons of um kurt cobain and courtney
love
i'm alex from full house
my brother's nicki
he actually plays barry on
the flash my twin brother my savitar
how would you describe your childhood
with the family that raised me pretty
good i mean
i didn't understand him very my stepdad
very much my step-dad was
a little bit different than i i've had
ex i would expect
but he had a loving heart
he whatever we wanted whatever i wanted
he got me
to the best of his ability now
i mean he wasn't
the best
dad in the world but it doesn't mean he
was the worst
he um
everybody might let's just say everybody
makes mistakes
everybody does wrong but at the same
time everybody should deserve your
chance to be forgiven and
[Music]
move on
and i and if he's watching right now
richard phillip
for all the stuff you've done to me
which don't doesn't need to be mentioned
you're forgiven
it's even forgotten
i want to be a family again
i miss you
it's nice
you make it through high school
yeah i'm i graduated
did you do any uh time in jail
uh i did prison
i did seven years in prison i did 110
days well
a few times in jail the longest i did in
jail by itself was 110 days but i've
done it i've been in jail a few times
seven years was for what
um
assault
um
burglary
where the assault that was actually a
case that i had to fight because
because of a person
[Music]
that the family knew
no need to mention names
was money hungry and took advantage of
the opportunity
and
didn't get the money that he was wanting
so he took advantage of it and placed me
in jail for something i didn't commit
that's what you were talking about
earlier yeah yeah i see
and then after you're done with school
what'd you do
um
well
i started
a job i went out got a job tried to
was about to get my own apartment then i
wound up and i wound up in jail wound up
losing everything and
now i'm homeless you've been homeless
for how long
over a year well off and on for the past
seven eight nine years
in different states
of jail
in different states
mostly in the state of louisiana but
also in california because i've been
here since august
i was just trying to i came here to
california just to try to find a way to
get my uh to inspire my family to love
me again
it's hard being without my family i miss
them
i make a lot of fuck-ups but i miss them
i mean
bros i'm sorry if whatever i said to you
i'm sorry if i if i could take it back i
would but i can't take back what i said
i can only just go forward
i would i could never kill my family let
alone anybody else
i can't even kill a pigeon that had a
broken wing i all i did was nurse it
back to hills
i hate murder i hate death i love my
family i want my family back
what happened with your family
they disowned me
because of what i said
i threatened to kill them i threatened
to burn them alive in their trailer
while they were asleep
i was just had so much pressure on me
and it leaked out the wrong way and i
said that and
after i got off the phone i just bawled
like a baby i was like oh my goodness
why did i say that
so i came here to fight tooth and nail
to make sure that i can inspire my
family to love you again
are drugs a part of your life ernest
yes methamphetamine
crack
alcohol cigarettes marijuana
how long you've been using drugs uh
since i've been here i've used before
but
on a regular basis since i've been here
since august i i've even gotten to where
i shoot up now
i'm not addicted to it but it's it only
settles the
the pain
it only it only blankets the pain i
don't do it to because i'm addicted to
it
i do it just to make just to
feel a bit of relief
because nobody here
has been able to find a way to get me
help because i'm from a different state
this is the california republic y'all of
rio's own state and country
it's like america split into two
different countries
and
i can't i i can't win for losing i try
to get up on my feet
and i fall down or
people tell me to go to such and such
and such and such and such location to
get help
i do and they turn me down
the definition of insanity is doing the
same thing over and over again expecting
different results i'm not going to get a
different result
so where do you stay at night when
you're wherever i'm where wherever i can
lay my head
which it gets pretty damn cold at night
sometimes sometimes i have sleep and
freezing my freezing every bit of me off
some that's why i deal with sinuses all
the time i deal with diarrhea i deal
with sick with uh
ailments but not illnesses
how do you make money
prostitution
and that'll that'll keep you
fed and get your drugs no it's not so
much fed it's just
it's
just so i could
whenever i do the stuff like that it
just it it makes me feel it doesn't it's
not the fact of prostitution is the fact
that
being around someone that shows
compassion
any type of any type of compassion
that's why
because i'm looking to be loved
i haven't been loved in a long time
in fact i've been pretty well hated
do you feel like do you have any friends
i don't know
i'm hoping so i'm hoping i might but if
i do
it would be a surprise because
if i had any friends
if if those that claim to be my friends
there's so many people that claim to be
friends that are that just use you and
just throw you to the side
i
honestly i don't know of anybody that i
could say is my true friend don't let
unless one day so they pop up and say
i'm i'm actually your friend and
well it would it would surprise me
it really would i'm not saying
that it's
impossible it's just it'll surprise me
because i feel even though i'm around
everybody i thought i'd be alone
like nobody understands me nobody gets
me
there's one thing i do have to mention
that the world needs to know
what's that
uh before i do
uh this is gonna be a little bit on the
kooky side okay
a little bit of the you know the little
nonchalant might some people might think
i'm crazy type
the family of
[Music]
kurt cobain courtney love
their two sons
isn't of earth
i'm we are extraterrestrials
i'm go 10 son goku
i'm an alien
you're an alien
yeah where from
uh
planet duffel
well not tefl dollar tefl i'm planet
vegeta there's three planets
two of which are y'all are in a trinary
system
you all have three sons
one son to the uh home of the annunaki
nibiru
uh planet vegeta home of the sands
the war the warrior race
and plant itself for the home of the
planet plants planet earth
there's been a big
whoop to do about um
whether extraterrestrials exist or not
this is what even trump has been waiting
on being been setting up for
been waiting for the day of unveiling
extraterrestrials are real
and we are not alone the earth is not
the center of the universe does the
earth look like the does the
if the earth is the heart
of god
does the earth does this where the heart
is located at in the chest does it look
like it's
apart
oh does it look like the center of the
universe no the center would be more
right around here
if anything
um extraterrestrials have always existed
they've been created they were created
in the very beginning when
whatever created us created us
we are all in a sense god
but at the same time we're not
god doesn't the true god doesn't come
down because it's not
it's not a physical
being it's a physical being it's not
even it's a spiritual being but it's
more us in a sense of laws and
and precepts
are you are you religious earnest
yes sir i'm i don't believe in being
religious i believe in uh having being
spiritual
i follow spirituality
i don't go i don't go to a church i
don't claim to be a member
i don't i'm not against them
but at the same time i can worship god
right where i'm at it doesn't have i
don't have to go to a building
it says it says in
in john chapter 4
uh verses 19 through 24 it says
whenever the samaritan woman came and
spoke to
jesus
or whenever jesus went and spoke to the
samaritan woman she said sir i believe i
believe that you are a prophet
uh
you s that but you jews say that you
should we should worship in jerusalem
we worship
up here on this mountain
jesus said woman the hour is the hour is
the hour has yet come and it and yet now
is
when the true worshipers of god will
worship him
in spirit and the truth for the father
seeking such to worship him
god is a spirit and those who worship
him must worship him in spirit and in
truth
ernest what to
what do you worry about what are you
afraid of
nothing
i'm not afraid of anything or otherwise
that song that i wrote would be a lie
because i am the only friend
because i am the only [ __ ] real one
and i don't need to bring the big guns
yeah
that would be that would be too
too much of a true song i don't fear
anything
i don't even fear death
i just mourn i'm being
being fearful is being is
fear come
fear or happiness or sadness comes in
many different varieties of arrays of
spectrums
i have no fear not even fear of losing
my family or not getting my family back
i just
am
how can i say this um
remorseful for the very stupid word the
very actions and stupid words that i
said because
in life it says in scripture
that you shall leave your mother and
father and cling to your wife
i'm 37 years old it should be time i
cling to my wife and
it's not my fault i haven't found the
right one yet i had the right one
something come up no need to exp i'm not
i'm not
i'm not gonna even explain it because
there's no need to explain
any of it just
i lost i lost my true love
something come up something had happened
and me and her separated
she had she buried my children
you have kids
yeah
how many kids eight you have eight kids
yeah she uh had a um
they call it let's see quadruplet
setuplet sextuplets
seth tuplin
uh
octuplets yeah octuplets she had
octoblets
eight kids at once
not at once but before you know if you
know what i mean of course
you know within durations of time yes
but she had eight kids
her name is uh vivian elizabeth
or serena
have you been in their your kids lives
i really if i didn't know i didn't know
she had my kids i bought whenever
something this had come up and i'm not
trying to mention it because i don't
because of my family she left me
or because of my family i left her
because my family told me she cheated on
me and she was my true love i would have
wound up in hollywood if it if it hadn't
been for my family i would have wound up
doing being a very very productive
citizen of society
but
what did it happen did you have goals
for your life did you are the things you
wanted to do yes
i had a lot of ghosts
serena's amy lee
evan essence
that's my serena
i remember the picture i seen on
facebook that is my serena
that is the one i fell ahead over heels
for
i me and her were engaged in
in in hunt county in tawakkany in texas
we were together she this was when she
was before she left texas
and
how can it be that she's much older well
imagine time zones being different
timelines
that would be more appropriate
for it to make more for it to be more to
make more sense how much older is she
than you
i'm older oh well i was older than her
but
before but now she's i don't know how
she is
before she was younger than me she was
about four years younger than me i was
18.
well obviously she i was 18 she was
about 15.
but i fell in love with her
i wasn't gonna ever hurt her
but until she hurt until she hurt me by
being when i was told
quote unquote she cheated on me with
with two guys
that she
cheated on me i don't believe in
cheating i i believe in
having a firm founded faithful
relationship
a wife and kids
but instead you're living on the beach
here in santa monica
homeless
say that again but instead you're living
homeless on the
yeah california
i can't get back to where i'm from i've
tried i've tried i don't have no money i
can't get enough money and
the money that i do get i need because
it takes money to survive even
especially being homeless what brought
you to california
to inspire my family to love me again
i always want that's what all i was
wanting is to inspire them to love me
again
i miss them so much
i miss my i miss my cook my aunt rose
my uncle nathan my aunt my my cousin
nelda my cousin michael
which
this is going to be a surprise to them
no to michael
well not michael but note him
you're my daughter michael's my son
you're one of god they're two of the
eight
we have another one named sarah
where most of them were raised in my
family
dealing with it wasn't with sarah
wow
is this the lowest point in your life
right now huh is this the lowest point
of your life right now most difficult
part yes
can't be easy living on the streets it's
not
do you have good do you have good
memories in your in your life
yeah that's what i live by i live by my
good memories and
faith in god no matter what i know he's
gonna pull me out of it eventually but
it's never when i when it's never when
we want him to pull us out of our
situations or to help us or to do
anything for us
it's always in his time
i'm just patiently waiting in hopes
without sight
only by faith because
i hear the voice of god
very faint very gentle
very loving like a like a
father full of unconditional love
but
i only only live by faith
so all i do is live by faith i trust
them i trust god
ernest what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
most important lesson i've learned in
life
don't take anything for granted
live
today like it was your last
but don't live it
to the fullest
live your life
according to
loving god first and foremost and loving
your neighbor
so let's just
love each other
and live
happily ever after
because i i can't stand war i
every time i hear about war or anything
going on it sets my nerves on him
i love peace i'm not i'm not about chaos
i love peace
all right ernest thank you so much for
sharing your story
i wish you the best of luck out
there thank you
you